[Music]
welcome back to another off the record
aka
the careful boys
we're today featuring
carol
the careless women the
today we are going to talk about roe v
wade
yes
you [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm candid
i won't
we already talked about it no no we got
a prompt today we do have a prompt uh
and the question is especially because
we have two
wonderful women here say that again
uh we have a prompt
if you woke up as the opposite sex for a
day
what would you do for the day
complain you prompt that with
wait i'm so confused i would absolutely
jack off okay sorry let's start with the
chicks let's start with the chicks all
right what do you mean well you think
you're going to answer that
technically
yeah i'm a chick now i won't go back um
i woke up as a chick yeah
are you even listening a woman
[Laughter]
are you [ __ ] listening to me that's
what you do that's the first thing you
do complain
[Music]
[Laughter]
interrupting complain yeah okay no but
yeah what would chicks do when they
first wake up am i aware that this is
only a one day cursion oh what's the
prompt mister yes you are
you are aware that you only have this
power for 24 hours
well i think after i feel myself up as a
man
i will go
as a man
uh i think after filling myself up as a
beautiful woman what is that what does
that look like
less is more
what the hell is
i'll figure it out as i go okay you guys
have many years i don't know how to do
okay
um and then
and then i'm sorry to all the women that
joe has had sexual experiences don't
worry you only want only one has to deal
with it right now
that's a joke though
somebody preps with this
[Laughter]
and then
and then
um i will ride a horse i want to see
what it feels like a lot of horse
without anything in between my legs
bareback
oh
why
i feel like that's way because horses
bounce
that's an appointment you got to set an
appointment and i just think girls look
like on a horse than a bicycle
it's just majestic looking so i want to
look [ __ ] dope when i do [ __ ] yeah
yeah throw your hair back yeah i'm about
a tricycle
that's cool too but it's got to be the
big ones that you're in the lake with
and you look like a big [ __ ] dork
i want to look cool but it's gotta be
like a big [ __ ] dork
another thing is i would like to
wear a skimpy outfit
and walk into places that might be
dangerous to experience that
i want to see what i'm pathetic
yeah yeah
and then i want to fight a man
and then see the difference in like
strength yeah and speed you wouldn't
want to like fight a woman to see what
that feels like once
that's a good one
hilarious
yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] his jujitsu friend kicked my ass
she's really good though yeah you know
her justine
oh you have to prop that with she's
really good though she's a woman but
she's good
but get this look at this she's good
[ __ ] joe's wife kicked my ass too all
the girls in the school kick my ass but
but then i want to fight a man
okay just a street fight and see what
that feels like you know what i mean and
then
um i want to see like also
my dms
and read my you only have it for one day
bro start a new instagram because i can
do that all in one
[Laughter]
all people do is scroll down a little
they're like he used to be a guy
[Laughter]
what's your new name
it's just a new profile picture
josefina josephina that's too close
they're going to know you came from
joseph
how
are they just going to scroll how are
they going to know
my instagram changes into the woman when
you wear your skimpy outfit yeah how are
you going to sit
like like this
hey uh
let's take out i want to [ __ ] sit
like this better yet describe what
you're going to wear i'm going to wear
uh oh like one of the outfits as uh the
girls at sapphire
they're naked bro
no
these tits are going to be out all day
yeah it's like a it's like a mini skirt
but the ones that show the bottom butt
cheeks
is he turning you on yeah
bro i'm like yeah what else joe
what about some tassels i'ma wear a
match under something they don't wear
tops at sapphire
but they do right before the show starts
so he wants to catch them as they're
walking to work they do now i know 6 p.m
is when they take off okay what else
okay so it's a it's a tube top i think
that's the correct color
red red sexy i like red it takes gets a
lot of tension and it matches my black
hair so like i
read bottom red top would you show some
under boob or side boob yeah definitely
no no
you're also a cheekbone i'm writing
joseph no it's a tube top i don't think
it's it's possible so scratch that
you're gonna have to fight this one i
want a tank top with the side boop not
the tank top what do you call it when
it's like a triangle here sure i get it
i'm talking about oh yeah sure one strap
on the back
of me and then you got the side boob
right there okay i dude that should be a
fact josephine is going to be popping
what is it called
i i don't want to mess up his flow it
looks like a baby bib yeah yeah i got it
yeah okay cool do that [ __ ] okay cool
[ __ ] heels to accentuate what kind of
heels platforms oh of course dude you're
going full ranch man you should be able
to predict this so you want a hooker
[ __ ] yeah okay i'ma look like a hooker
okay how do you flirt with men i don't i
just walk down the street and then see
the confidence she's like i don't i
don't because with that they're gonna be
like hey baby how much and then what do
you say i go
oh what [ __ ]
specifically for joe's character
i think he should keep his regular voice
everything else oh that'd be amazing oh
dude and then you [ __ ] yeah yeah
so like when he gets really upset like
joe's voice comes out and [ __ ] but then
like or as soon as joe kicks him he
turns back into joe oh
yeah that's true i like that i like that
in my legs grow hair right everything
just like [ __ ] my nipples all hair
you're like whole thing right
yeah how does he grow back into joe
though does the girl's skin explode or
is it like a crossfade transition oh
that's amazing
it's a star wipe the cross face like
inside out and the girl on the outside
goes dissolve left
like which one is it just the imovie
transition circle
yeah roll inside basically
the new joe just comes
yeah what is it which
that's a good that's a good idea because
this guy's dissolving left
someone's like seeing it i want the skin
to [ __ ] fly off of me like that's
what i was thinking man that was great
and then i turned into this firecrackers
do fly yeah
i think it'll be pretty cool um yeah i
want to bait i want to bait guys
i want to bait them
up i'm going to throw your curve ball
let's say you
turn into you wake up and you're a woman
right
and then the minute you wake up it's the
wrong time of the month and you got a
big old bloodshed yes
you got your [ __ ] period bro yeah
you want to eat chocolate and you feel
and you feel all bloated and you're like
man i got all these plans buying doing
[ __ ] today yeah or not what you [ __ ]
hooker now
how about my period so leave me alone
son of a [ __ ] give me some chocolate
this one got two phones
[Laughter]
same conversation though
because i think okay that means you dial
both at the same time all right well you
know what's gonna happen wow is if i
turn into a woman then hannah turns into
a han is going to be mana all right
man man and then josefina and manna i
like it and then this one i'll [ __ ]
call nick
and then i'll i'll just like nick
yourself [ __ ] go get me a [ __ ]
chocolate manna
uh i'm not gonna call you some [ __ ] but
but man can you [ __ ] be nice to me
today and [ __ ] go do something nice
yeah bring back some flowers just
anything but then i'm gonna be like on
the other side and be like yo i can't i
got cramps i i'm in bed all day because
you're on the trail yeah so i'll be like
yo i can't do anything so we all turn
into girls and we all
but midday we get our period you know
what i mean so our cycles just starts we
experience the day as a woman half the
day and then we're live speaking of half
today we're halfway through the video so
let's hear from a woman who took no no
we want to talk more
i don't know
you want me to call you right now
anymore all right uh [ __ ] uh geno yo
what's up gino
dripping down my [ __ ] dude hook me up
with some help
nah stop being a [ __ ] that's exactly
what i say
gina
damn man blood guys are so mean what
would you do you're a man now what'd you
do what would you do for a date how do i
follow that [ __ ] like that's so good
just your own personal what would you
like as a man i want to do all of that
but like the reverse okay so let's hear
it walk us through it you could do a lot
of man [ __ ] already though i already do
a lot of magic i mean yeah you lift
weights and stuff i guess i can walk
around topless
you know like i want to see what it
feels like i don't i feel uncomfortable
i don't really like that i feel like he
would be really buff too you're all
offended
as a dude when you think about the
epitome and the privileges and luxuries
of a dude i feel like i'm already a lot
more masculine than a lot of men would
you just pee everywhere would you just
pee oh yeah you could just like pee
outside of food for less
that's a drink yeah i do i mean i can
kind of already do that without having
to whip it out you know what i mean like
you could just pee wherever you have
zero curiosity you don't want to jack
yourself off i do for sure i want to do
that i want to see what it is the truth
is your truth tell us without us having
to pull can you stop [ __ ] talking
over me you [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah absolutely gonna jerk off see what
that feels like uh i'm gonna try to have
sex with all these [ __ ] women
and see what that feels like
you got sex with a lot of women now but
no but it's different because i don't
get to penetrate maybe you're not well
endowed yeah
yeah it's not about you
man it's not about the size of the boat
okay it's about the motion in the ocean
did you say that when you lift it up i'm
gonna throw your curveball yeah but yeah
i'ma throw your curveball let's say you
have a nice pretty dick right but what
if ran into joe's hooker and he kicked
you in the ball
and you're making but what if what if
yeah erectile dysfunction
now you're gonna call
then there
something happens all the time you have
erectile dysfunction i know i said
for your 124 hours but we're all
dysfunctional we're all dysfunctional
though what about you ryan may i feel
like you're the most creative guy here i
think wait
if i become a woman i could still do
everything i can do now
like physically i can do your hair
that's my curveball you are a paraplegic
woman
i go i just wake up and go looks like
i'm a woman
you're a female version of you
you're a female version of you so
whatever that means to you looks like
i'm
i would i would do um i would enter a
dance battle using everything i could
already do and instantly win that [ __ ]
because i'm not gonna have i don't have
a chance as a guy
he knows what i'm talking about i do
that's so good you know what i'm talking
about damn there better be a jam on that
one day that you're alone but then right
that day all the guys are all the guys
are girls anyway yeah [ __ ] today's only
qualifiers so it's all the best b-boys
that are now women too and i lose still
like oh great thanks
what would yours be
yeah we want to hear what you want to do
and no you don't wake up with [ __ ]
braces or something
you have no ears go
you have a retainer your handicaps your
penis is at your knees girls don't want
to [ __ ] that's a handicap
um
i'd compete in boxing
oh
damn that's the most that's something
you've always wanted to do
i'd fight but
in the men's division but using women's
when she says
you just identify as a man well you're
the same hey that's her curveball she
she's fighting as a man but she keeps
her woman's arms
dude that sucks man
yeah because i want to kill the
difference boxing then because it's like
round one fight
[ __ ]
but then the guy's not gonna know what
you guys should just fight right now i'm
not only [ __ ] but the guy was turned
into a woman that day too everyone's
everyone's just caressing each other
everyone's all mixed up round one fight
what the [ __ ] is going on you wanted
this you want to see you could literally
just stay guys to do that by the way
[Laughter]
so you would you would fight as a guy
but would you want to fight a woman
no as a guy
i want to fight a man nice does you
already know what it feels like to fight
a woman right so do you
yeah that's true
that's true
yeah i do want to see the strength
difference though i think i'm really
curious about that like just being able
to lift certain things or like just you
know feeling the body of like oh so this
was like okay that makes sense yeah with
that voice
oh my what is this it's like oh oh this
is a period oh damn that's not good man
oh disappearance you know yeah
or like oh [ __ ]
i lost all sorts of directions what the
[ __ ]
is that left or left
where am i what
what's the difference between left and
north
yo triple a got here really fast who do
you hang out with because they sound
stupid dude i'm just like canceling
myself thank you
the smartest [ __ ]
[Laughter]
what a fork that's
i would
play the dj of course because i didn't
understand what that feels like yeah he
really does like
play the dj
he's like please help me yeah he needs
to figure that out i need to figure out
the dj
that's good and then try all kinds of
textures like okay let's see um
spray on i thought he was going to say
put dicks on my mouth
no this is gender neutral everyone has
one
that's true
i feel like man lips are different than
women lips though for real no they're
the same
have to challenge go
yeah
immediately
different textures so spray on
vegetable oil see if that feels
different wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait yo i'm so happy
men don't have a vagina that [ __ ] is
[ __ ] wrecked ky jelly to see what all
the difference is get a hot towel put it
on see what that feels like
see if it actually feels good see if i
get a balloon can i blow a balloon
just try different things play play tug
of war with myself 24 hours you're not
gonna have much time for much else dude
yeah he's done
this might be finished in three minutes
by the way
i'll get a slim jim you guys can get a
figure i'll get a slim jim right i'm
afraid of what you're going to say next
bend it into a u and see if i can play
tug of war with myself
run in each hole and see who wins who's
stronger the vagina or the [ __ ]
right by far you're the most creative
dude
you're over here right he's the most
creative yeah he wanted to enter a
[ __ ] dance battle dude i want to see
who's going this guy's tug of warning
himself with a slim jim in two [ __ ]
holes you're accomplishing much more or
they can do the lady and the [ __ ] and
they both eat
[ __ ] ladies and [ __ ]
they're eating each way to a little kiss
at the end
how do they
can you demonstrate he's got sentient
buttholes just can't do it on the spot
are you gonna do it like this or you're
gonna do it like this like that like
that like that like this oh okay like he
needs to watch
i gotta watch he's got a mirror here the
whole time just looking at it every time
and then and then
outfit like a i don't know like an
evening gown like uh like what would you
do evening
fuchsia sheen [ __ ] with the [ __ ]
strings
and then with the uh with the with the
heels and then with the you know when
you when they go like this and they they
let go of the iron and then oh it
bounces
and then they go
and then i go see what i can get away
with at the club with dudes what are you
gonna try i would do that too by the way
i'll go to the club first
or dude let me drive his lambo
would give me a thousand bucks yes
all of it is a yes
can i get can i get [ __ ]
four bitcoins
four bitcoins well what if you woke up
you're ugly
oh yes
that's you don't get a thousand bucks if
you're what if your conversion is ugly
that is the biggest curveball of all
it's not a curveball because men will
[ __ ] go for anything oh yeah there's
ugly guys in there that is so true but
he's got he's got his curls though
especially the ones with look at
anthony's roster yeah
that's true
all you have to do is just keep dropping
[ __ ] you're just like
oh
dude he's got it oops yeah
oops
oops
[Laughter]
i hope he has broad shoulders too
it takes a while oops oops
he's going to [ __ ] scrape it off
all right and you still get mad you're
still like hey my eyes are up here man
and then i'll try to pass the test or
something i don't know that's a test see
if it's which test
than driving a dmv oh
you're like i don't use these signals
you